what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel welcome to my
co-host today thanks for having me I'm
Chef Dawn tell them where to find you
Chef Dawn on YouTube that's
c-h-e-f-d-o-n now today we are going to
be interviewing the people whose fault
is modern dating in 2022. whose fault
you think it is women
I don't know I think sometimes it's a
guy sometimes it's the guys you know but
you know it could go either way we'll
see what the people say before we start
don't forget like the video subscribe to
the channel let's get started I'm here
with Dakari Gemini Shannon Jamia Toya
Brianna June Lucas Chase
who is to blame for modern dating men or
women and why because it is then why
because I think for themselves they only
think for themselves do you think that
men are clear about what they want no
are they confusing yes because they
don't know how to be direct mama say man
why social media they compare like girls
nowadays to Instagram models who's to
blame for modern dating men or women I
guess yeah I guess I gotta say men you
got to say yeah your girlfriend leads a
relationship no no I wouldn't say that
she definitely said I got to say
personally I would say that maybe men
have messed it up I don't know are
modern women wipeable yes yes
yes you were talking about Instagram
models they're comparing you to them
what's wrong with comparing you to uh
Instagram models if there's no problem
with the current woman yeah yeah nothing
wrong with
them and I'm just saying that now
there's just a lot of expectations like
relationships don't last as long because
people are like oh I want the Instagram
model with the big booty and what about
you same I agree with her group think
huh who's at fault for modern dating men
are women women because they're so
indecisive do you think women tend to go
for what they want yes they do go for
what they want if women go for what they
want why do they say they like nice guys
but continuously go after [ __ ] when
someone treats you like [ __ ] like you
know you want you go after that because
you you want something better like you
want them to change you want them to act
better so you keep going after that
person because you're hoping they're
going to change so why don't they just
go for somebody that's acting right from
the start because they want that person
to treat them right they want to know
why that one person treats all these
other guys are treating them right they
want to know why that one person is not
treating them like all these other guys
so that's what makes them go to that one
guy our men or women to blame for modern
dating but enough more or less okay so
men I feel like men view women at a
certain uh perspective and then men uh
they they act that out and then women
they see that and they act a certain way
that they shouldn't men and women so so
both of them will set the tone for it
and then it just kind of [ __ ] up the
sequence so you got these certain
perceptions because you've been hurt in
the past and then you go out and you
know you putting that hurt on to other
people instead of healing yourself go
get therapy who's to blame for modern
dating men or women both one or the
other like more or less men or women man
I guess I don't know men men I can
follow up that question by why are you
single like what's going on because
nobody wants to take anything serious
you're playing games too no
there's no not oh come on come on you're
a woman not one no how do the games
usually go I take it like they want to
have their cake and eat it too they want
to deal with multiple people
they're like [ __ ] with you but
they're [ __ ] with a bunch of girls oh
man why because I mean we're dogs you
know wolf wolf dogs you think men are
just cheating all the time I think who
cheats more you think men or women women
be the dogs you know men cheat but we
got feelings when we cheat men have the
feelings when they cheat yeah
so you think when women cheat they have
no feelings no no man we do have
feelings because we feel some type of
way whenever we find out like somebody
cheated we feel something I'm confused
I'm confused right now dang they're
they're more hurt than if the women find
out for sure for sure and isn't it worse
when a woman cheats oh yeah yeah you do
feel it yeah
yeah I feel you for sure so then why do
you say that matter
the blame for cheating if women are more
or to blame for dating if women are more
likely to cheat because I think men
instigate it you know I'm saying like
man like instigated but women when they
do it it hurts more what has been your
experience with with dating like before
you were uh taken who was the problem
Oh bro man I don't I don't even want to
get into the [ __ ] but uh the I I was
uh groomed from a young age from men
that were way too old to be around me my
parents let them be around me because
they took the problems off their hands
I'm talking like why the hell was I 16
leaving school going to a trap house
getting liquor your parents were
encouraging that they they didn't have
the space to really control me because
they're too folks on work that really
set the tone for my life to where I was
looking for validation for men instead
of getting it from my parents and then
that led me into situations where I was
very easily abused taken advantage of
laid on the wrong path I'm talking I had
a dude I thought it was my baby daddy
for four years I'm talking you ever made
something uh a child of four years well
I got pregnant at 16. and and a dude
thought he was a dad for four years and
quote unquote he pretended well he
didn't go get the paternity test so he
could make me his [ __ ]
was he your the dad oh hell no
so so did he know it might not be his
the whole time yes but he never went to
go get the paternity test because as I
said he wanted to make me his
and I'm talking I went back to him was
trying to help him so much because
because the lack of validation from my
parents I was like trying to fix men
trying to fix him were you cheating on
him hell no was loyal I was loyal how
are you loyal if the kid wasn't hit
okay no you see I'm just a little okay I
got a question okay so okay I guess I
should get in so okay when I was 16 I
was being groomed into so who my kid's
dad actually is was a trick and you know
at least I loved that dude instead of
the tricks so that that's why I was like
you know I'm gonna go do that whatever I
ended up telling the trick and he he
asked for my only fans because he was
like I'm so stressed out
four years later yeah what what's a
trick and come a little closer to us
again what's the trick a trick is a dude
that pays women money for whatever
whatever whatever they want so did you
give us your stripper name or your real
name yeah my stripper now I'm gonna go
to work right now my first set of women
do you think are wife material and do
you think your wife material I got
issues
um but I like to say a good life maybe
like 60
60
yeah you know it really depends on the
circumstances like you know have you
been in therapy have you gone through
your issues are you sitting here
bringing in problems into a relationship
are you emotionally aware are you
spiritually aware do you know how to
communicate and you know do you know how
to say oh I'm wrong and you're not going
to put that on somebody else put the
blame on them be a narcissist
essentially so yeah about 60 of women
because I I like to think a lot of women
they they don't really they don't like
to self-reflect uh it makes them feel
shameful so they'd rather put it on
other people especially the people in
their relationship oh well I did this
because of this this and that but hey
you look at a bad person you look at a
good person every single person has gone
through a bad situation is how you make
that situation you know anybody could do
anything to you you can act how you want
to you can react how you want that's how
you have your power without trying to
sound more cliche than what's out there
already the media because everybody
talks about everybody shaking ass this
and that and blah blah yeah sure a lot
of people are being exposed for being
the IG model or the one that's out there
like no the patriarch any stuff I can
come down but there are still a lot of
good women out there that want that
wholesome life that want to stay at home
take care of the kids do this and that
so I would say the media which sounds
cliche as [ __ ] and soaked like
conspiracy-esque that I think it is or a
little blame on that or wholly to blame
on that all right what brings you out
here divorce so you're single that was
my follow-up yes I just like recently
divorced so my main goal was to move out
here and live my best life are you
single yes I am at the moment what does
living my best life mean do whatever the
[ __ ] I want
it's perfectly fitting for this question
right who's to blame for modern dating
men or women in my personal opinion I've
been with my ex for 13 years I'm 35 now
and honestly like the divorce was pretty
much both our faults right it could have
done more and he could have done more
too but I'm finding out now in the
dating world is extremely different than
what it was 13 years ago it's harder and
more confusing from what you see like
you know on social media and all of that
who do you think's effing up like the
most men or women I see a lot from both
sides they say women are [ __ ] up
because we're too independent now are
you a Democrat no oh interesting not a
republican either oh gosh you got you
just just because like everything's not
50 50. I respect your answer for sure
but you know somebody has to be more to
blame right so like whenever you're on
the internet
you know you said we see only fans now
we didn't see that before you know we
see some guys are more aggressive than
than what not what do you see more that
you don't like of I would have to say
it's them being aggressive who do you
think's more to blame for modern dating
men or women I probably say women I'm
gonna say it's us the men I feel like
women got a lot of control you know what
I'm saying like they get to pick a lot
they get the they get they saw the balls
in their Court you know I'm saying they
get to make a bunch of decisions on
based on who they talk to or what they
want to do or where they want to go news
we like fighting an uphill battle you
know what I'm saying and in your
relationships whose core is the ball in
pause if if I'm in a relationship the
ball is in my court you know what I'm
saying and then it's up to her if she
wants to be in that situation and if not
then that's cool you know what I'm
saying but again you get a lot of
independent women that want to do their
own thing you know I'm saying and don't
want to be in that situation so you know
I'm saying it's up to them to choose and
make a decision for themselves this man
fault because we had a power to give it
to y'all you know what I'm saying so we
gave you all the power so we
relationship we did it so you can't
blame the woman you gotta blame the man
what percent of women are wife material
in 2022. she got a good eight you know
eight percent yeah white material yeah
what percent of women are white
materials [ __ ] yeah man you say eight
percent eight okay eight percent is cool
I thought you said okay that's good what
percent of men are husband material I
was just talking to you I was just
talking to the homie about this a dude
can have every a list of things women
ask for good job make money boat house
all that [ __ ] and they'll skip over that
dude they don't want to talk they don't
want to talk to that dude they want the
challenge and they're gonna go holla at
you know some dude that's sleeping on
his homies couch or some [ __ ] like that
you know like I've seen it time and time
again you know I'm saying more power to
him whatever you want to do that's up to
you I think we're in the same boat yeah
for sure we still want to [ __ ] around no
matter what so you know what I'm saying
probably eight percent eight percent
eight percent what percent of women do
you think are wifey material percentage
that I think would probably be white
material maybe 40 percent
35 percent
I don't I think women want that
Dream It's a facade for them you know
what I'm saying they can talk a big game
and you know I'm saying they want XYZ
but whenever XYZ happens it's not for
them or you know I'm saying they're
trying to back out of sales situations
what would you rate yourself out of 10.
I get myself like an eight I give myself
like eight you know I'll be a little
humble hey yeah should I got my own car
my own apartment right he lost his car
like six months ago let him take my car
to work all that I do my dues you know
make sure I hold it down so I'm good I
keep my communication up I can you know
tell somebody when I have my faults and
if and if you tell me I'm wrong hell
yeah I'm wrong because I'm not going to
tell you that how you feeling is not
valid no disrespect do you think that a
lot of men are attracted to women that
do sex work oh absolutely but they
fetishize them and then okay so have you
ever heard of them her commitment I mean
like commitment do you think a lot of
dudes would want his wife have you ever
heard the Madonna complex what do you
think a lot of guys would want a wife a
woman that does sex work well the
Madonna complex goes into that so
essentially it's a psycho experiment by
us I think I ain't even gonna say his
name I'm a butcherant but it's a psycho
experiment where men they're attracted
to women that are sexually flamboyant
attracted to but do you think they would
want to date them but they also they
shame it so they go for the women that
are more wise and material but they
can't connect to the women their wife
material because they view them as their
mothers and they want to respect them
more so they're thirsting for one type
of woman while simultaneously not
wanting a woman they chew it they cheat
with one and then yeah with women they
cheat with women like me I've seen it
plenty in my work line plenty plenty
plenty so you're they don't respect us
and they don't respect the women they're
with because they got some sort of
discourse going on inside themselves
where they essentially there's a there's
actually an experiment where when
whenever men look at women like me they
view us as objects instead of people so
what's your final answer are you do you
think men are attracted to women that do
sex work like for a long-term commitment
not long-term commitment for for a
temporary you know fulfillment what
percent of women are wife material in
2022 40 how many bodies is too many
bodies for a wife to each his own I've
always said
I could be messy but not dirty
do what you're gonna do and just check
yourself and make sure you got no STDs I
think you're sugarcoating the answer I
think that I because right now
those are some of the cleanest if we go
by textbook they're the cleanest by your
definition they're getting uh yeah
tested every week oh no absolutely but
that's why to each their own right so if
you say 20 then 20 is the top to where
they can be messy yeah well we're asking
you to to you all right what's your own
oh my quote uh 20 to 30 I guess I mean
agreed yeah you know what I'm saying so
like you know if a girl's like a dime
right like your ideal woman but she's
like yeah so I got 50 buddies what
you're saying we can talk it through you
change your values because the girl
looks good no not because she looks good
depends where the relationship is based
not because of the physicality
where we're at right because it takes it
takes a lot more than that right the
looks will take your interest
pass that all right how we vibing how
are we doing what's going on you're
about to go down to the altar right and
you heard your girl had four trains ran
on her in college you still marrying her
probably not I mean that might be a dip
biker for me personally you know what
I'm saying absolutely like that might be
a Dilbert because I'm probably not or
definitely not definitely not yeah
that's a dill Baker you know like
I I try to pride myself being as
Progressive as I can but I there are
some Antiquated ideas that I need trying
to stick to and that's one of them like
I might look at her different I might
look at her a little bit different and
that's gonna I'll be [ __ ] me for the
rest of the life so it's going to be one
of those things where like no thank you
facts me too
hey this is the real me too
I've heard this saying the best way to
get over one man is to is it to get
under another so have you done that
that's a yes how many times how many
different dudes
foreign
[Music]
how long ago did you get divorced
March but I've also have separated
mentally and emotionally and physically
longer than that wow amen what they say
is correct women know and they plan
their exit is that correct do you think
that's correct absolutely absolutely
we're we're calculated but it's not to
say we're calculated in a it all depends
on essential again every situation is
not tailor-made you can't fit any type
of situation into a box there's all
different type of people situation
standpoints boundaries when when was
your last relationship my last
relationship was two years ago and did
you break up with him yes I did and how
long before you broke up with him did
you know you were going to break up with
him I would say probably six months into
our two-year relationship okay so I I
would say that's about typical that I
got about six months before yeah six
months before yeah maybe he's he's
scared he's like yeah we know that's
just scary man how long have you been
single for who said single you know how
long have you been single for or if
you're in a relationship let's just say
a figurative number let's say five five
that's just a number I just don't know
why okay no I'm just curious
just curious why I like this topic of
dating oh so you want me next gotcha you
think I'm cute wow you have nice eyes
thank you
a nice lot of things right
it could be number four I could be
number four since you're since your
marriage was he a black dude no have you
had any black dudes no
hey man there's no time like the
president I'm six foot two and I could
be the one for you
you got some bad little kids no no
they're teenagers they're teenagers
facts facts so you singled in oh no no
are you taking I'm engaged for how long
how many years oh
almost like three years show the ring
show them the ring come on come on come
on
okay
okay what do you guys look for in a guy
how tall does he have to be just taller
than me I'm five five
most common thing I hear it's like my
height or taller yeah what do you think
how tall I say over six feet almost six
feet so five eleven no no
now there's just a lot of expectations
like relationships don't last as long
because people are like oh I want the
histogram model with the big booty and
what about you same you can't make this
[ __ ] up people
cannot make this [ __ ] up um do you guys
have like um how much money he has to
make requirement like would you guys be
cool if they didn't guys that makes 30
000 a year I mean it just depends on his
goals that he has for him so as long as
he's like working towards something yeah
what about you any money requirement
um no I think he needs to learn how to
manage his money but that's about it as
long as he's like paying rent and stuff
yeah no no in your mom's basement no who
cheats more men or women I talk to
mostly guys because I just have my
girlfriend so I would say any dudes that
I talk to or like friends of mine they
probably not all of them cheated but
like someone has cheated probably why do
you think a lot of modern women won't
take accountability they're shamed of it
they're ashamed of it because I feel
like a lot of women have grown up to be
pressured into fit a societal standard
so if they have to own up to their
wrongs it's shameful and they don't know
how to feel that shame move on and do
better who's the blame for modern
relationships
I don't want to say the word I blame
social media
we want girls one
social construct of social media it's
just corrupt
it's just bad and they have these like
unrealistic expectations and so instead
of being realistic about relationships
they feed off what's on social media and
then it affects them in their present
can you give me a real life example of
that okay for instance if you want
talking to that girl we won't need be
here right now you know what I'm saying
if you want talking to that girl we
won't be here if you would have never
said she was cute we would never be here
we'll be happy and we'll be you know on
a date right now what's what's wrong
with saying someone's cute that just
means his eyes are working don't give a
damn baby I'm cute why can't you both be
cute because
so like if Odell Beckham walked in the
room you're not gonna look at him
my man him and I'ma take him that was a
contradiction
he's just the man and that that's that's
a bit of me of the dating scene right
now do you think most women are wife
material most No No Song yes what makes
a girl wife material I guess it depends
on the person do you think there's like
a general though thing that men look for
it depends person because some people
are like okay with some stuff some
people aren't so is there like a general
thing though you've never heard from
most guys well I guess they look like if
you can click clean take care of them
and all this [ __ ] is like your wife and
you can see her but that has nothing to
do with the person so do you think most
women can cook clean no I won't say most
yeah so would you say most women aren't
life material though
I know you mentioned that you know a lot
of guys are playing games but do you
really think that you're looking in the
right places if you keep finding guys
that are playing games with you I'm not
looking I'm waiting for him to come with
me don't you think that would be like
kind of your fault that's why you're
single like have you ever heard the
phrase if you want something go out
there and get that [ __ ] I mean but why
are you sitting on your ass waiting
waiting for something to come to you I'm
gonna change something up if it's what
you're doing is not working
the right one to come don't you think
that's the problem with modern dating
right now is women are waiting for Mr
Right while Mr Wright is looking for the
woman that's not even looking for him no
because that doesn't mean I'm like I'm
just not gonna chase you but you want a
man to chase you no I want you to show
effort and show interest you don't have
to chase
if you chase you that means they don't
want to be chased they don't want you
you have to chase do you like a girl
that chases you Loki I do that means
that they're put in an effort for me and
they're not chasing other dudes that
means they actually care about you a
girl that's nonchalant Loki like maybe
at first they act nonchalant but if
they're chasing you it means that
they're putting in the effort uh and
they want your commitment in my
experience but why do you think this is
so common like we hear this a lot it's
really common like girls we don't want
to chase a guy why I think that uh from
a young age women are told that uh
they're queens and they don't have to do
anything so they you know other than go
out there and get money for whatever
reason just so they can spend it on
themselves but women are told that
they're the queen and a man needs to do
everything for them while they can just
sit there were you told that no well
were you told that no what were you told
I was the time okay you've never used it
you've never used a phrase black queen
to a woman that's never deserved it that
has nothing to do with the conference
but that's what I'm saying women are
labor but you're not supposed to chase
but that but that's what I'm saying we
men don't just go out here and just King
King King you're a 10. women are just
like yo she's a queen but she didn't but
she didn't do anything I'm not saying
I'm not saying you're worthless but I'm
saying is like you're not necessarily a
queen if you haven't done anything to
make yourself a queen you're a queen if
you have a king with you you're a queen
with her without them that's like saying
I'm a millionaire without money
I definitely encourage you to you know
go out there like if you see Mr Right
Out There
go and talk to him he might like it
because how many guys out here are
getting approached somebody but that's
not chasing exactly that's what I'm
saying we're not chasing you we're not
telling you to chase them what we're
saying is approach him you said you've
been chilling just sitting doing your
like you're not looking I mean I'll say
something but I'm not gonna chase you
hold back then we on the same we're on
the same page you said Chase we on the
same page then okay would you say modern
women are wifeable I think marriage it's
more like a photo op I think the
generation I'm a millennial but
Generation Z marriage nah ain't
happening do you think you're gonna find
a woman that's you know wiping material
out here in the streets yes or no I
ain't mobbing the streets for wifey
materials
how many bodies is too many bodies for a
wife yeah I say this ain't nobody gonna
get married right you know what I'm
saying
in 2022 it's not no [ __ ] I really look
for what like that's right it ain't like
I'm asking or some [ __ ] but I know it's
way I don't wanna know I don't want to
know I'm not going to ask as long as you
clean we're good I'm not gonna ask no
questions like I don't want to know what
you did and all that [ __ ] that's but say
you found out what what number would be
that deal breaker I mean to me it ain't
really a deer burger
that don't matter to me don't tell me
that [ __ ] I don't want to hear that what
if she says she says hey you know I just
I just want to be honest with you I'll
tell you shut the [ __ ] up don't tell me
I have four trains wanna run on me what
she says
she says that what you said don't tell
me I'm gonna say it
I'm going home no time you better hop on
the train back home
okay
what if she says what if she says 25 you
staying or going 25 is not bad how old
is she is she my age 25 she's 25 or 25
buddies 25 at my age 32 that's not bad
okay okay what if she says 45. what you
want me to do with that
deal breaker though
I ain't gonna lie I ain't gonna lie
listen to me listen to me trains are
different trains are different
what percent of women do you think our
wife material in 2022 and what percent
of men do you think are husband material
I love them you gotta train your man how
you want them so right now he might not
be husband too but by the time I get
done with him she gonna be a husband
okay if you're gonna train him to be a
husband what would you do what do you do
wrong right now
do I look like I have problems I mean
y'all what problems you got on contact
for one what's wrong with that none of
my word contacts no more but they cute
on you you give them like a Chris Brown
Vibe but yeah what's the problem you
just say they look cute I mean yeah they
do but don't work I think you put a lot
of girls that's your problem
like a look at her she can't stop
looking at you
oh well damn she looking at me then
I think all women are wife material yeah
so I'm worth material your wife material
yeah out of all those girls at first
when I got my boyfriend I wasn't so you
feel like it's like the responsibility
of the other to to make do you think you
know what he got to do to make me happy
I know what I got to do do you think
that's fair to go into a relationship
trying to change someone no no no no but
you kind of are if you're if you're
trying to make them into something like
a husband or a wife yeah no that's not
changing nobody
but you just said that you got to mold
them that means if you have Play-Doh and
it's a blob are you changing it no I'm
just saying if you know I don't like
roses don't bring me roses every day
bring me what I like like that but what
do you mean by mold what does mold mean
I didn't say mold you say mo no you said
I said you got a modem you said I did
yeah
hey Shout Out Future
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible